[Music]
i'm trapped here day after endless day
with my one maniacal
nemesis
four complaints this week four this is a
period when you take a period and put
that donut hole away or i'm gonna shove
it up
you two are the worst part of my job
we're gonna be hiring a managing
director we'll oversee each department
the job is mine shortcake if you get the
job i'll resign just like you will if i
do ah but i'm incapable of giving you
that pledge well it's not the first time
you've said that to a woman is it
are you and he like there's eye there no
i hate him with a passion
wowzers what's the occasion
psychological warfare i wonder what it's
like to be using raw animal magnetism as
a weapon i had some weird dreams last
night i was in bed naked
i have a theory
what are we doing this game that we play
every day hating someone feels
disturbingly like falling in love with
them
let's play a different game a starting
over game why i don't want to be some
experiment before you settle down
[Music]
we are competing for the same job it's
impossible to trust each other i'm in
this you can trust that
i told you she'd back off if you let her
think that you could pet the pony i
don't need any help beating her
you would just do whatever it takes to
win whatever this is i don't want to do
it anymore
i don't understand you i thought you
hated me
so what game should we play now
[Music]
lucy when you first met josh what did
you think i thought he was cold and
freakishly uptight i thought lucy was
just fine let's kiss ass it was hate at
first sight
[Music]
bye